The content in this nano degree will
help you learn the most important
devops, concepts and practices.
You will have many chances to apply what
you have learned by completing projects
and getting feedback.
But you are probably much more
interested in knowing how that will help
you do your job better or
maybe you want to get a better job.
This is where your very
first project comes in.
What does it mean to work better?
How do you measure
the success of a project?
To see improvement,
you need to know what to measure and
then you need to measure
changes over time.
Right now, we are not talking about
monitoring server CPU load or
measuring click-through rates.
We're talking about what you want to
improve in your everyday work and
how you can measure improvement in that.
That's the first step towards
the goal of continuous improvement.
Your task for
the first project will be to identify
problems that you face at your job,
both organizational and technical.
How do you know that these are problems?
What would an ideal scenario look like?
How will you know that
things are changing,
either for the better or for the worse?
This project will be a living document,
you will start it
now at the very beginning of the program
and you can update it as you continue.
You can mark the areas where
you don't have the knowledge or
resources to find a solution.
After you have learned a bit more,
you can revisit those sections.
And if you don't have an organization
to think about, don't worry.
Maybe you are just between jobs or
just starting your career.
We will provide a story about
a fictional company that you can use for
this project, if you'd like.
Before you get started on your project,
let's look at some general
issues companies face.
Then we'll look at specific issues with
our fictional and very troubled company.